Speaker 1: We are really getting very close to the
2022 midterm elections. And what I want to do is
take a look at some of the most important races,
potentially what we might call bellwether races,
also potentially difference making races as far
as the U.S. Senate is concerned. See where things
are and talk about where we go from here. Now, a
little bit later on in the program, many of you,
dozens and dozens of you e-mailing me over the
weekend about so many of the incredible debates
that took place over this weekend. Marjorie Taylor
GREENE debating her opponent, Marcus Flowers.
Herschel Walker debating. Raphael Warnock. Ron
Johnson debating Mandela Barnes. Kari Lake. In
a very strange CNN interview about whether or
not she would accept the results. We're going to
look at all of that. But to first set the stage,
let's take a look at some of what I consider to
be the most important races, either because they
could be the difference maker in who controls the
Senate or because they have some other particular
importance, like the Pennsylvania gubernatorial
election now. I know people are going to email and
say, but David, sir, you missed this race or you
missed that race and it's so important. I can't
look at every race. I'm also not looking at any
congressional races in this segment because
it's very unlikely that the congressional
balance will depend on one seat. And so there's
just so many congressional races to look at that
I'm not doing that right now. But let's just start
going down the list and see where these races
stand. First and foremost, Pennsylvania governor,
Pennsylvania governor matters so much because
when you look at swing states for a presidential
election and then you look at which of the swing
states could be the sole difference maker and who
becomes the next president of the United States?
Pennsylvania is at or near the top of that list.
And Doug Mastriano, the Republican candidate in
Pennsylvania, is openly running on a big lie
campaign platform if given the opportunity. If
Doug Mastriano is the governor of Pennsylvania in
2024, he gets to choose the secretary of state,
which oversees the election, and he will pick
someone who would be willing to just straight
up try to steal Pennsylvania's electoral votes. If
a Democrat wins and they don't like it, they will
try to steal it. For the Republican, this is an
extraordinarily important race. The good news here
is that Josh SHAPIRO, the Democratic candidate,
is winning by an average of ten points. That
is a significant lead. I'm not going to
say this after every one of these races,
but assume nothing. Everyone must vote. This is
just a reflection of where the polling today is
best based on the best data we have. There's still
time. Things can depart from the polling, but this
one so far is looking pretty good. Josh SHAPIRO
There's very little to say about Josh SHAPIRO
because he's so uncontroversial. Some might say
he's milquetoast. Others will say he's just a
completely normal person who isn't going to try
to steal any elections. This one is looking good,
and we really have to hope that Josh
SHAPIRO does win. Also in Pennsylvania
is the Senate race. The Senate race is
television. Dr. Mehmet Oz against the
lieutenant governor, John Fetterman, as is
the Republican. Fetterman is the Democrat.
John Fetterman had a stroke months ago. There
is now a big campaign in which Oz's campaign is
participating. Even if Oz himself is less overtly
participating in it. They basically say because
of the stroke, Fetterman can't be a senator. We
already addressed that last week in quite a bit
of detail. The good news here is that Fetterman
is winning. The bad news here is that Fetterman
isn't winning by that much. Right now it's about
a three and a half point margin on average for
Fetterman in recent polling. Pennsylvania is
maybe the most important state in the midterms,
both because of its the Senate race and it's
the gubernatorial. Our friends in Pennsylvania,
I hope every single one of you is planning to
vote Florida. Florida has a very interesting
Senate race. And again, the Senate may come
down to just one seat. So every one of these
big Senate races is important. Incumbent
Republican Marco Rubio, kind of a pathetic
character. There's just something about him that's
very pathetic. He in a bad way, not in the old
philosophical sense. He is facing a challenge from
Congresswoman Val Demings on the Democratic side.
It's not looking great for Val Demings, but this
is still potentially winnable. Rubio is up by
somewhere between four and five points. We will
be carrying the debate between Rubio and Demings.
You know, it might have been rescheduled.
So it might be tomorrow. It might be later
on in the month anyway when it happens. If
it does, I will carry it. Florida voters,
you've got an important race there as well. Also
in Florida is the gubernatorial race. And again,
when we think about I mean, listen, think about
Florida. Florida could be the difference maker
in who becomes president in 2024. But moreover,
the guy who wants to be reelected as governor,
Ron DeSantis, may end up being the Republican
presidential nominee in 2024. So this one is
doubly important. And as I've said before, it's
not looking good for Charlie Crist. The Democratic
challenger, Ron DeSantis has a comfortable lead
of just under eight points. That will be difficult
to overcome. But listen, all of our Florida
viewers should be voting regardless because
of that Senate race. So when you're there, you
vote for governor. We try to get Ron DeSantis out,
even though it is an uphill battle. Then we go to
North Carolina. This one has not gotten that much
attention, but it really should because it's so
close. Cheri Beasley is the Democratic nominee.
Ted Budd is the Republican nominee. It's
almost a tie. Okay. If you look at the
only polling from the last month. Okay. It's a
tie. And the Republican plus one and on average,
including earlier polling. Real Clear Politics
has this as a one and a half point lead for
Ted. But let's not sleep on North Carolina.
And I know there's the assumption in North
Carolina the undecideds are going to turn out
for the Republican and all the different things.
What? What better thing do we have to do
than vote? Okay, let's just let's vote
and let's see where we get. But that's a race
not getting as much attention, and it really
should. North Carolina, you can vote for Cheri
Beasley. Then we go to Wisconsin. Wisconsin.
I'll be honest, I don't really know exactly where
this race is going right now, because there was an
absolutely humiliating debate over the weekend
where the incumbent Republican Senator Ron
Johnson, was booed. He was openly laughed at and
he bombed in his debate against challenger Mandela
Barnes, who, by the way, Mandela Barnes has been
a guest on this program. You can go check out in
the archives on YouTube or on our Web site, my
interview with Mandela Barnes. Super smart guy.
Barnes crushed the debate. So all of the polling
I have is at least eight days old. It has Johnson
leading by just under three points. Even if
that's the case today that Johnson is leading by
about three points. This one is possible. And the
disastrous debate performance for Johnson over the
weekend may hurt him further. So this is a very
important race. This is a possible seat that can
be taken from Republicans. Then, of course, we
have the state of Arizona, two important races
there. We covered the Arizona Senate debate.
That's incumbent Democrat Mark Kelly challenged
by MAGA. Trump is Blake Masters. Blake Masters
is horrible and dishonest and unethical and just
vile. A gross gross guy. He scrubbed all of the
violently anti-abortion stuff from his website
after the primary, but now is kind of trying
to explain it away. And he can't. He is a big
lie proponent, although he downplayed that during
the debate a week and a half ago with Mark Kelly.
Right now, the good news is Kelly is up four and
a half. The bad news is Kelly should be up 40. But
Kelly was not particularly good in the debate.
Kelly is not like an electric, exciting guy.
So if you vote in Arizona, not only do you
have this Senate race, but you also have,
maybe even more disturbingly, the Arizona
gubernatorial race in Arizona. The incumbent
governor, Doug Ducey, is leaving and there is
an open seat. The Democratic nominee is Katie
Hobbs. The Republican nominee is one of the most
aggressively weaponized from a disinformation,
big life standpoint candidates. Carrie Lake, she
is. Trump endorsed. She is. Trump loved right now.
It pains me to say this. Kerry Lake is winning
by just under one point. And the last two polls
that were done, an insider advantage poll and
an AP poll, each has lake ahead by three. Kerry
Lake is a lunatic. Again, it's sort of like if
Herschel Walker were to win. If Kerry Lake wins,
it is another serious humiliation for the United
States. Our Arizona viewers, you in Pennsylvania,
you've got a lot on your shoulders here. We really
have to do everything we can to prevent Kerry Lake
from winning. We then have in Ohio Jp mandel right
now, J.D. Vance versus Tim Ryan. Tim Ryan is not
the best candidate. His debate performance
was not exactly beautiful. But J.D. Vance
is a trump ass kisser. Exactly the way that Tim
Ryan described him in the last debate. And sadly,
J.D. Vance is winning by just under one point. And
the polling seems to be moving in Vance's favor.
If you vote in Ohio, this is a big one. And then
lastly, in Georgia, we have oh, I've got to do the
Herschel Walker win as well. Second to last, the
state of Georgia. It's incumbent Republican Brian
Kemp versus challenger Stacey Abrams. Stacey
Abrams is extraordinary. Kemp is horrible and
Kemp is winning by five. Okay. So our Georgia
voters, many, many extraordinarily important
races for you. And let me just get the Walker
Warnock numbers up as well, because those are so
important in the Walker Warnock race. And we will
get to their debate a little bit later. Raphael
Warnock is up by a hair over three points, but
Herschel Walker is gaining on him. So, Georgia,
I know he didn't do Texas, Georgia, Pennsylvania
and Arizona, multiple important races. I hope
everybody there is voting. We'll get
to the debates later in the show.